what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
start do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
the way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos as you guys already know
if you have watched two or more of my
lives and you do not subscribe we have
beef okay beef people so a couple
announcements before we start the show
the first being that we have two clips
channels the first is just pearly clips
and the second being
um Pearl daily we have two different
editors on those accounts so make sure
you subscribe to both to get two
different types of Clips next we have
four membership tiers the first you get
to be a part of the chat the second you
get to be a part of our Discord and you
get to see our behind the scenes Vlogs
third tier you get to connect with us on
social media and fourth tier you get a
one-on-one call with us once a month
um I really recommend this if you are
trying to grow on YouTube I have helped
people get to ten thousand twenty
thousand thirty thousand subscribers um
I also help on Tick Tock in just a
couple of sessions so if you want to
grow on YouTube I would really recommend
that route on top of that I am Shadow
band on on Instagram right now so make
sure you go type out my Instagram name
it's just dot pearly things you have to
type out the whole thing in order for my
name to come up because I am Shadow band
we just hit 50 000 on Instagram so let's
try to get to 100K next I have two
different tick tocks they took away my
first account took away my second
account took away my third third account
but you can't get me off Tick Tock so go
follow me on Tick Tock justperlythings.4
and dot five shout out to whoever took
both of those usernames before I could
we got we got beef actually
um also guys um I think we've gotten
like 30 40 000 subscribers in the last
week so thank you to all of you for that
we are getting closer and closer to 500
okay so uh make sure you subscribe to
the channel and help us get to that 500k
Mark
um
we're gonna do a Members Only Live soon
and also
um last the number one super chatter of
the stream gets to be on the board
behind me so last stream
um we had Thane Mitra and the word he
wanted on the board behind me was the
wall is undefeated so
yeah I mean you can kind of you can kind
of see it
um also guys we are not gonna this is my
last show before I go to the US for two
weeks so I'm going to the us tomorrow
I'm going to be on a bunch of podcasts
in the U.S
um I'm going to be going to New York
Dallas
um potentially Miami potentially LA and
um Vegas for sure so if you guys have
certain podcasts you want me on in any
of those cities go spam their chats and
tell them I am going to be there in the
next two weeks
um while I am gone we are gonna have um
auntie and Michael are hosting on
Tuesday and they are actually going to
be doing shows on their channels on the
next two weeks they're going to be using
the space using the guests that we get
coming in
um so make sure you go subscribe to both
of their channels they're in the
description okay so I'm done with my
announcements so
um today we have a lovely panel so why
don't we go around everyone say your
name your age your relationship status
and a fun fact about yourself starting
here
hey people so my name is who is Kai on
Instagram
um I'm 28 and I'm single uh
I've got the last question
um your name your age your relationship
status and a fun fact and a fun fact um
father of one
that's that's the only fun fact I could
think of to be fair
my name is jakayla I'm 27 I'm single and
a fun fact about me I recently qualified
to be a massage therapist
that is fun
um my name is Jay Dean I am 27. my
relationship status is unknown and
um
fun fact about me
I've been single 10 years
um
that's a long time
that sounds like an unfun fact okay
um go ahead yeah I'm Headley uh 39
relationship state is single fun fact
used to be a pro kit boxer huh
hello I'm ayush chairpuria I'm 38. I
just recently got married a fun fact is
I'm also a book writer oh no
yes my name is China I'm a 38 in a
relationship it's the third time I'm
back so fun fact the comments are loving
me okay
um so today's topic is can modern women
be saved
um now the question is
can you turn a hoe into a housewife
[Laughter]
why don't we go around you can start
with myself
it depends I think if the right man
is with the girl then she can be changed
into a housewife so it just all depends
on the individual the influence and the
circumstances that they've been through
for their life but I've been with girls
that may have had like numbers behind
them and I think that when they was with
me
I perhaps could have changed them into a
housewife but it's not every woman so it
could be just that particular person but
again it goes down to the individual
okay what is there um anything that a
girl can't come back from
it depends when you say that that's like
an open question
um is there anything a girl can't come
from it depends on the situation like
because I'm not really I'm not I don't
really judge people so I couldn't really
say that there's something that they
couldn't come back from but me
personally
as long as I don't really ask too much
questions about your past because once
you're with me I'm all about our future
so I don't really focus on what you've
done before me so as long as you're not
carrying on with the stuff you was the
stuff you was doing beforehand and it
wouldn't really bother me and this and
from where I'm not gonna have like maybe
a friend approach me and say yeah she
done this then I don't think it's really
going to be a problem but that's just my
personal perspective on it okay what do
you think me
um I think many have tried I don't
really know
I don't really feel like it's possible
um I believe that a leopard never
changed at sports so yeah
I'm I'm always a Believer
um
I feel like I've actually had
conversations with guys about this and
I personally haven't been in that boat
but I know a lot of girls do end up
being the housewife and a lot of us good
girls be like hey what did I do wrong
but I feel like some guys do feel like
when a girl does have enough experience
and they've gone through all of that
stuff like having to change guys or like
sleep around and I'm really really
trying for these girls
um I'm trying to play Devil's Advocate
um why but simply because everybody
deserves a second chance just because
you've done something when you're
younger doesn't necessarily mean 10 baby
mamas 10 babies I thought we were
talking about a woman
as long as it wasn't wow it was with me
because if it wasn't me I'd be like
before he matches okay
today I'm not really the type to really
go for the baby for others okay but for
them today yeah yeah no no no maybe
you've done like 10 years from now maybe
I might look at the situation different
because I'll be a little bit older to
the point where like who do you exactly
think doesn't really have a child at
that age
why'd you say that because I don't
neither does he whether you both don't
have kids seeing that does that's not
very common though about five or six or
seven of my my friends all in the same
boat no kids all professional or make
money or majority of people I know have
kids I'm like literally like I'm like
one of the few that don't I'm like that
goldfish in the tank is like how come
you haven't got kids yet why I don't why
do you not in that way but like
I'm not in a position to want kids yeah
so I just think that it's just probably
where you're looking because if you step
out a little bit further a lot of people
actually don't have kids or they don't
have baby moms or or they lie 50 of
women that hit 30 are single and
childless actually
oh they they're childless
for the people that I know to my
knowledge I'm going from what I know I
don't mean they didn't kill you yeah
I just know a lot of people lie so you
might feel like somebody doesn't have a
child or they have a child and they
didn't know they had a child
okay
um
why don't you go
uh turn a hoe to a housewife no
why not
I think it depends on your definition of
a housewife but if you're talking in its
traditional way I would say no I think
too much experience
a lot of negative ones I think for
someone who would fit the definition of
a hoe I don't think I think by then
they're just damaged goods but what is a
hurt though yeah yeah that's a good
question that's my next question so why
don't you two answer and then we'll talk
about that
my definition of a hero is a girl has
stepped around a lot indiscriminately
um
I couldn't necessarily put a number on
it but I'd say
a girl who's not really been concerned
about whether she's got any connection
with the guys that she's been sleeping
with she's just been having a good time
racking up the body count
I would consider that to be a whole okay
yeah I feel that you can easily change
to one as all you need is probably just
a change of culture because that's what
you'll have to do first thing when you
change your culture and stay somewhere
else
so you do you think you can turn a how
into a housewife definitely for the time
being for sure
I like that optimism for for how long
a lifetime not lifetime but definitely
for the first two months
so you can turn into a housewife for two
months and then her her hoe comes back
she's like the streets are going to the
streets
okay now you can't turn the hole into
housewife
no no no
can you turn a hoe into a wife yeah it
happens all the time yeah because then
if you look at all these rappers they're
doing all the time 24. yeah but if you
look at rappers as your idol then your
idolizing celebrities we don't look to
rappers as as of course but in terms of
looking at people who are turning hoes
into Housewives they're the majority of
people who are doing it how long do the
um do the marriages last probably not
long because if you're looking at Kanye
West and King Kong that didn't last
longer suddenly these are very bad
examples to use very bad examples then
she's not away yeah she's just short
term if she was a what she was a wife
but she's not a wife
that's true maybe it depends on how
people interpret the definition of a hoe
then because then some people might feel
like certain things like women have done
in their life that's that's not really a
hurt so yeah let's let's ask the man
what are you when
when is a girl become a hoe
a girl becomes a hoe when she has to
start lying about how many people she
slept with automatically you're holding
because from the moment you start lying
you're not even being true to yourself
um so that's when it starts so the
moment you have to start lying to
yourself and lying to other people your
whole so if she is honest and says 50
she's not a hoe oh no she's still a hoe
but she's just an honest hole
we respect the honest ones as well yeah
no I'm still not gonna wifer but I
respect the honesty so here's the thing
I remember we said before a woman has
the right to choose a woman has um the
right to wear what she wants a woman has
autonomy is sovereignty of her body a
woman can have consensual sex whatever
she chooses to be but those are the
woman's rights and men have our own
rights and doesn't mean we have to take
it for that so what we're trying to say
is women can do whatever they want we
don't judge you personally but us as men
have with certain standards and we don't
want to be the woman that slept for
example my friend or a friend's friend
or something like that men and women see
sex differently
um a lot of women argue that they don't
and they treat it the same but you women
still don't mind seeing a guy that sees
a lot of other girls with us man we
detest that but what what if like um
I feel like the reason why I'm I feel
like I'm standing for certain women is
because what if
their psychological problems what if you
are judging somebody from the cover of
what you see them as but they actually
are somebody that just deserves good
love what if it's somebody that is
willing to change their colors for you I
think that's a feminine point of view
because we always try to change man okay
but like from the man's point of view
it's like once you've lost your Purity
it's gone but okay so somebody could
judge me per se they might look at me
and be like okay I don't like the way
that she dresses I don't like her point
of views but if it was a thing where you
sat down and we was to have like a night
out just me and you as girls and I told
you about my past and the reason why
I've done certain things and like I'm
ready to like give myself to somebody
that I really trust and really love do
you not believe I deserve a second
chance I mean I think no one deserves
anything
fair enough I think you kind of it's
like what do you qualify for and so it's
it's if if you you know did certain
things in the past like I just think
you're eliminated from certain guys but
don't worry one of them three Mana
virgins are haven't had sex in the past
year there's someone so the girl is
someone I just think there's there's a
lot of onus on the men put that we have
to accept bad behavior previous stuff we
no one is no one has to allow anyone's
previous history that's why if you've
ever done a crime in the past before
that you know if you go for a job some
jobs you can't go for and that's just
the way it is so I think a lot of times
women want us to
to be counselors and be psychotherapists
for their previous trauma which we had
no parting and that and that is fine
if the guy that once she's prepared to
take that but you shouldn't go into the
world thinking that anyone has to be
there to to fix any of your well I'm
trying to figure out is why men
most men always get looked upon like
like they're not a who why is it
different for women than it is for men
because men and women are different they
are because they are because it's easy
for us to get sex the world doesn't like
think highly of you if you do what's
easy
and men getting sex is hard so if they
do what's hard it's valued if we do
what's easy it's not
so for you for example for you um as a
lady you're very pretty um attractive
thank you um black woman and and on
Instagram I haven't seen your Instagram
but I'm sure if you put on your
Instagram every single day that um you
you was lonely and you wanted some
company I'm sure you wouldn't have any
problems with people messaging you or if
you asked you ask the people to take you
out but if one of us did that and said
that we wanted sex we would probably
have our Instagram shut down now the
difference with us is okay if if if in
order for me to sleep with a hundred
women
um especially quality beautiful women I
would have to have some type of value
about myself in order for you to um
sleep over 100 men you don't have to do
anything but just say it and you can
just walk down the road and you would
find men that will sleep with you
um so that's why but what about men that
lie what about men okay for example I'm
a pretty girl if I do say I'm lonely on
my Instagram and somebody does come or
approach me in a way where like they're
coming across as they're good and then
they've lied to me or made me feel like
they were going to do something good in
my life and in the it turned out that it
wasn't that all I ended up giving myself
to somebody and now they're like yeah I
don't want to do you anymore so now
that's added on a number to the previous
guys that I've done before and it comes
across the I'm a home and realistically
that wasn't the situation yeah it's like
how many times are you gonna get
bamboozled but like I think most guys
like okay so like if I'm at home too
they're like all right but like when
you're like 20 30. but we found my
husband buy all of them wherever my
hopeless romantic no you may you make
bad decisions so why does it necessary
to be bad because you've slept with 10
or how many people and nothing's come of
it so for me as a man all those 10
previous men you slept with they don't
add anything to me they're just men that
have used you and now left you for me so
what you've been better of you doing is
is is vetting those guys better your job
as a woman is to vet the [ __ ] that
is not our job you need to mitigate
these men that come into your life and
say which one is is he seriously she's
not serious if you give up the goods
every single time a guy takes your
number takes you out for something to
eat that's up to you because they're the
ones that lie though no but this is also
up to you because you you have to you
have to differentiate between the men
that lying the men which don't lie if
you cannot um separate the good men from
the bad men whose fault is that that's
not General sometimes it's kind of hard
to tell We're not gonna like sit here
and be like I think that's that's
[ __ ] come on that's [ __ ] you
know as a girl as a girl you you know
deep down you just you're just trying to
sell you you just want to change them I
hate you you don't let him down which
guys in a room you walk into you know
which ones are getting laid you know
which ones aren't but they love it
anyway
not necessarily what if I'm not trying
to get laid what if it's a thing where
I'm literally trying to know you as a
person do you want to date someone that
no one else wants to date
no girls love the bathroom I kind of do
though I don't know so you just said it
yourself so you go so you're going for
guys that you already know that a lot of
women want so these are these are men
that are obviously they wanna they they
high value in the sense a lot of women
want them whenever you go for these
types of men you have to understand you
you are just one you could potentially
be one of many and you don't want you
don't like being you don't mind being
one of many there's probably some guys
across the years that I've always
probably tried to holler at you tried to
take you out and you haven't given any
time to These Guys these ordinary
ordinary I don't know but it's fine but
what I'm trying to say all of these guys
have watched you deal with all these
guys one by one one by one and it never
amounts to nothing at some point you
need to say to yourself maybe I am going
for the wrong types of guy maybe this
guy is not right for me maybe I need to
stop going for what I like and maybe I
need to start going for what makes sense
but this is the thing with females I
think I feel that they don't get to that
stage until they're maybe more mature
like I feel like okay
that's when they start being a bit more
pragmatic about what guy makes sense
yeah until then so you've told what 35
for geriatric pregnancy so it's like and
unless you have twenty thousand dollars
to put down and maybe get a kid out of
it maybe like you gotta you at like 30 I
feel like people start getting dressed
for it I feel like when females get to
the age of 30 that's when they start
looking at the guys around them and
they'll be like you know what I'm tired
of being abused or tired of going
through the same old story so you know
what now I might go for the good guy
that may not have wanted me beforehand I
feel like the more than the modern day
kind of girls are a bit different though
not necessarily it doesn't necessarily
mean that they're looking for a child or
another husband sometimes they're
literally trying to get their money
build their next generation for it
doesn't necessarily have to mean a child
that comes from them they could adopt
they can do other options it's not just
you can't they can but the least happy
demographic of women is women over the
ages of 45 that make between I think
it's like
between 50 to like seventy thousand
dollars per year and are single and
childless like life is good about it
though what are they bothered about me
yeah they're the least happy demographic
like life gets pretty lonely after the
age of 45 like right I don't think as
women we really understand how different
the world treats us because we're pretty
women
and and because one day your looks are
going to be gone you're gonna get no
attention from men like 40 40 to no no
men are lining up to date 50 year olds
it's a good thing I've got personality
then isn't it that won't work that won't
work guys do you do you care about a
girl if a girl doesn't look good do you
care about a personality of course not
yeah well you guys if you're trying to
wife someone why would you not care
about their family no I said if she I
I'm careful with my words if she doesn't
look good you have to start with looks
not necessarily yeah for women you're
looking at it from a female point of
view for the men it's it's it starts
with looks it starts with sex so you
have to understand something before you
try to speak you have to understand and
accept what we're saying to you starts
with looks it does it does
it does because before I before you even
come and get your number or you want to
speak to you I've assess the way you
look so if you if I didn't like the way
you look why would I come and speak to
you in order for me to know your
personality that would involve us having
to work together or be in a scenario
where we can speak enough for me to know
your personality if a guy comes up to
you out of the blue try to speak to you
are you gonna oh my God he's got such a
handsome personality you don't know his
personality all you know is the guy
that's approaching you and whether or
not you want to accept his approach or
not listen to him or just give him air
so you also you so your first attraction
is based upon in that aspect in a
nightclub or outside setting based upon
attraction because you don't know what
the personality is and for females I
feel like a guy has to give a certain
image before you even take him into
consideration
someone had you but no that's just the
reality of it like for me I'm a short
guy I'm five foot four for me if I
approach a girl in a club I'm not likely
to get the same reception that my
brother would over there because he's
taller than me and he's more built do
you get me I'm short and I'm small so
it's like it's gonna be harder for a man
like me to move to a girl because she's
gonna look at me and be like that's not
really my type she won't even give me
the initial
like I don't know they're an issue but
you see my brother here you see that
type of um that blatant look you just
assess yourself when you said right
these are my strength this is whatever
men we have no problem in doing that do
you understand we can look at another
guy and say right this guy is this is
you um in comparison to me or whatever
his strengths on my weaknesses or my
strengths and his weaknesses right women
will look at themselves and they won't
do that same assessment and it's that
little bit of um you have to have
humility and humbleness and and you'll
get better results but us man we can do
that
I feel like women can too everyone was a
citizen
I feel like there's a little animosity
against women here okay sorry could I
just say something okay so before I want
to tell you a little bit about me I have
three sisters
um they're all married all with child my
mum and dad are together maybe together
for over 40 years
um I come from an African traditional
upbringing my dad is the chief of all
chiefs he was a diplomat very educated
man I have three nieces
um that are all directly look after when
it comes to women I'm a protector I'm a
love of my women so we take quite we
take it quite insulting when a woman
says oh we feel as if that you're any
type of hate towards women because
having a criticism or no but what I'm
trying any type of animosity or anything
that's not what we're here for what
we're here for is to show how much love
we have for women in actual fact we need
to have these conversations so I take it
quite personally when people try to
create that image or perpetuate that
image because if you don't know I'm
actually a very much support of women
and we protect all women over here so I
just wanted to say that
did you know that women find 80 percent
of men is unattractive
I didn't know that so A Lot have you
ever heard the girl say like medium ugly
like oh I gave him a chance he was
medium ugly I say cute ugly yeah it's
like it's hypnosis that's just your
level
[Laughter]
80 of men is unattractive and the
question is if you find a guy attractive
he's probably the top 20 percent of men
are you top 20 of women and that's what
we have nowaday and you can get this
data from dating apps because women only
swipe right between five and like 20 of
the time and if you ask a hundred
percent of women what they want in a man
they list 20 of men
um
that's where you have eternal like side
chicks basically
um
okay so we agree you can't turn a hoe
into a housewife
um when when does a girl become a hoe
do you want to take that
um
I think to a certain degree it's it
depends on who you're asking right I'm
asking you asking me for me
I can't escape uh
yeah like I said a girl that just sleeps
around if she's not interested in making
a connection with a guy and she's got
the mindset that she can be like men
where she can have sex without having
any kind of emotional attachment to the
guy
you know then and she's not concerned
about racking up guy off the guy off the
guy and to me I consider that to be
holish Behavior it's not behavior of a
woman who's really interested in the
long term she's more interested in the
short term do you ask girls what their
body count is no no
no
no I never have I don't feel like that's
a good question to ask because if you do
it's always going to come back with a
negative response or a lie but Paul the
reason I don't ask is because we don't
have to ask
say certain questions you can ask and
you know the body count there's certain
reactions that women with high body
counts give off
um and a certain energy so we can just
already just we we know so I want to ask
the girls do you feel like because as as
women I think we know a little bit more
behind the scenes than men typically do
you think that men can tell a girl's
body count based off of like your
friends and your friends friends
to a certain extent yeah to a certain
extent what extent in a way where
um there's a lot of girls that I knew
back in the day that had no intention of
sleeping around but maybe they might
have been with friends that have
possibly done all of that and then it
makes it seem as if like you do that
[ __ ] too sorry sorry you do that stuff
too so
it kind of gets looked upon like you're
you're one of them so no but like at the
same time birth do flock together they
do but why can't it doesn't necessarily
have to mean that the girl's doing the
same thing they simply mean it but
sometimes you have to carry yourself
with the kind of people that you want to
be like I don't know how to say it but
so if you're with the hoes you're at
home so when you when the police pulls
over your car if he pulls off your car
when three people in the car have known
to for drugs you're gonna get searched
as well that's because you're a couple
of three people don't know for drugs
um you know a lot of times in your area
there can be one good boy you know I
mean and he has some friends but just
because their friends you'll stay
together and you and your mom might say
to you or stop hanging around those
friends stop hanging around those
friends
um because they're not like you but you
hang around with your friends because
they're your friends whenever you get
stopped or whatever happens you're gonna
be
um
um they're gonna treat the same and
that's because a lot of the times mud
sticks so if you don't want to be known
as a hoe or or if you don't want people
to treat you like treat you like one
then if you're hanging around with girls
at a lot of holes then it makes it a lot
harder for you to be the one that's
actually different you know I'm trying
to say to you so it doesn't mean you're
a whole if you hang around with hoes
like there's always there can always be
one good girl that Jeremy's a good girl
but by a rule of thumb you might not you
you might not want to hang around people
which don't have the same type of
Interest or activity activities you
that's me personally
what are you doing when when they all go
out and they're upstairs in the room
with random what are you doing you're
downstairs playing solitaire
I was about to say play Nintendo Wii
Bros sometimes you're just minding your
business and maybe when it comes to like
having sex with boys that might not be
the same topics that I might not be into
but like behind closed doors when we're
not talking about boys and we're not
talking about sex they are so like
typical
topics that are like yeah this is why
I'm your friend so whenever a girl gets
a man most girls have always got one
whole friend most girls always got one
whole friend and they know their hoe and
no and they don't like to admit their
whole but they're their whole friend and
whenever they get whenever they get a
new man a lot of the times the man will
clock this whole friend and he'll say
certain things and you and you know I
mean he'll be like oh that your friend
that your friend he's not trying to call
your friend a hole but you don't want to
call your friend a hoe to your man but
we all know we all know and you know as
a guy we always have to deal with that
and it and a lot of times those friends
don't tend to hang around for too long
after that person gets a man or whatever
is because
your whole life doesn't represent what
they live anymore you know I'm trying to
say to you versus she wants to be going
out and doing certain things and now
you've got a man and maybe your man
don't want you to be there because she's
rightly single she can go out and you
know interact with other men and be
taken to tables but if you're out with
her now you automatically put yourself
in a predicament where other men can now
start speaking to you and if she is a
whole and known for being in a hole out
in the club every single guy in there
going to see you as a whole and there's
nothing worse being seen as something
that you're not and people treat you
like that and your man hearing that all
your girls out with some hole in the
nightclub
do you guys do you think you guys think
it's appropriate to go out in a
relationship yeah why not is it is that
a bad thing now
conduct yourself when you're out well
what are you going out for
yeah I can't let my hair down for five
minutes on my goals it's like why are
you fishing if you don't want to fish
I was having a good time oh so would you
go out for yourself to have a good time
yeah is that no seriously is that a
thing no you I mean that's just I'm just
telling you guys how men view it like
I'm just being honest like I listen to
guys talk all the time like if you're
going out all the time it's like you can
you can say like I I'm I'm not a hoe
right but if all your friends are hoes
you're going out to the club all the
time it's like you're dressing like a
hoe acting like a hoe it's like how are
they supposed to think you're not a hoe
same thing with a guy if he if he hangs
around a bunch of friends that I'll
cheat
if he looks like he's cheating if he's
acting like he's cheating you're gonna
assume he's cheating and you'll fall in
love because women love being cheated on
well then if you don't trust your
partner that is a problem in itself okay
he has not it does have a big trust is a
big thing a big thing so how does a
relationship work without it I mean you
yeah but like why would you put yourself
in that situation yeah like I just think
if you truly respect the guy you're with
like you wouldn't want to do anything
that would make him look bad and it
makes a guy like like as a woman you
want to make your man look good like
that's your job and so when you're
dressing like a hoe taking going out
with your whole friends to the club
where they're all hooking up with guys
and they're saying oh they're all doing
it but not me I promise I won't flirt
with anyone but I'm going to the one
place where we're bound to get hit on
it's like you you look bad as a girl and
you make him look bad so we're typically
we're talking about girls that have her
friends and when they go out not just
girls in general we're just talking
about the hoes when they go what else
are you going to a club for
I just find myself yeah I've I've
literally never heard
everybody I guess has different points
of views while men and men have
different points of views when it comes
to women but that that is very new for
me I must say
I I think
if it's new for you then I always ask
myself like what types of men have you
have you had like what types of
boyfriends that's why I said I've been
single for 10 years because I don't go
out okay so let me I don't do that so
so you haven't been single for 10 years
I have been single we had sex in the
last 10 years I have that doesn't
necessarily mean I was in a relationship
okay so so but you see this is the thing
that women do so what you was initially
I was thinking oh for 10 years she's out
I've been out the game she is you know
no you haven't because you've been
having sex like so so you've been in the
game enough to be able to have sex but
not in the game or not not enough to
secure a man a proper relationship so
you know how to have sex this and this
is what I said women can have sex any
day of the any day of the of the week
and you look to me a little bit funny
you've been ape in the last 10 years you
cannot you cannot keep a man okay cool
wait I can't keep a man because I
haven't been in a relationship for 10
years because I've had relationships
well well yeah well it just it just
means that the men you want don't want
you there's one for six yeah like that's
you guys understanding then I'll take it
oh no no I want to explain okay so put
it this way I have dated men and they
have not given me or made me feel like I
was safe enough to be in a relationship
let's just play that for number one
number two yes I have had sex that
doesn't necessarily mean I have to I've
had sex with multiple men it doesn't
necessarily mean that the person that
I've had sex with I want to be in a
relationship with them that's can that
can still be my choice and that can
still be okay of course so when I say
it's okay for me to be single for 10
years without a relationship I think
that's very normal so you I'm just
you're right it's normal nowadays like
nowadays it's not uncommon but it's
because modern women are side chicks I'm
not a scientist you said that because
okay it's it's this is my relationship
I'm not even saying this like to be me
it's just this is how relationships
start nowadays they start like how many
times have you heard of a situationship
so and it seems like you've been in a
situation I haven't you okay then what
else would you call sleeping with
someone
friends the benefits is that not that
the situation shows the situation okay
so and so so if you're in a Friends with
Benefits situation that's uncommitted so
what else is he doing you're side chick
I'm not a side jerk I feel like a side
chick has been to somebody's in a
relationship with somebody and then
they're doing something with somebody on
the side okay now the side chick is when
you're one of many chicks as a man as a
man as a man this this thing of where
you women have to believe there has to
be remain in order for me to be a side
chick it's not it's a it's a crazy
phenomenon if you were one of a
selection you're a side chick that's it
stop thinking that he has to have a main
one where he looks after you're just one
of many I'm not but I understand what
you're saying but I'm not okay okay if
you were sleeping with a man and he
wasn't your he wasn't your boyfriend he
wasn't your husband yeah yeah and he
wasn't and he wasn't and he wasn't yes
he's single and so were you so therefore
you just you was aside and growing
things see what you're trying to do
you're trying to move the goal post you
keep trying to change it now we're doing
good yes it's grown things but those
growing things still amount to you being
a side chick and not his main woman and
that's your opinion and that's okay
and that's okay this is the majority of
women in this day and age I'd say this
started from can I ask you over there
yeah I'm not saying it's not I'm not
saying it's uncommon yeah like that's
how I mean that's how most relationships
start when I ask people like it usually
starts as a situationship most women
start as side chicks in in the west I
will say in the west and then a lot of
the time they put pressure on the guide
to get into a relationship
yeah but we can see in case you don't
know this is this is a phrase that
people say Okay
um women control sex men control access
to relationships so unless you're gonna
get down on one knee and give me a gold
Rolex and ask me to be your husband then
what you have to do is you have to fall
in your femininity along for me to ask
you to be my girlfriend then I'm gonna
be like oh my gosh this girl is better
than all the rest of the women I want to
lock her down I want to go to the
Jewelers and buy a ring and give it to
you so this is a process that needs to
happen and in order for this to happen
you have to understand that process but
the moment you give a guy sex days after
that you've given them everything
already so there's no there's no need
for him to actually make you into his
girl or his wife the need to make into
his girl or his wife is because you
possess something that no other women
have if it's just sex and you give it
away and you're not a virgin to give it
to other men then we don't consider it
as something special and the problem is
a lot if I'm not looking for something
what if I'm not looking that's fine
that's also fine but I think at some
level yeah unless you're saying you
don't want to be you don't
then at some level you're going to want
something so so a lot of the things you
do in the past can affect the guy that
you actually meet when he meets you and
actually likes you and then he's like
okay cool you run through all of these
guys it affects us not necessarily I'm
talking to someone right now he knows
everything that I've done in my past and
it's fine no but that's fine but what
we're talking about
um you know men we like to feel special
and in a world today where women are
running up body counts and stuff none of
us want to feel like the woman we've
chosen it we wasn't her first choice but
what if my body Count's not home no I'm
not I'm not are you just speaking no I'm
not sure
no okay sorry sorry I was a bit confused
in this moment I'm not directly aiming
at you I'm just saying because you said
you were starting for 10 years old just
like we consider it as something like
this I'm not saying that's that's you I
don't know your body I don't want to
know your body count I'm just simply
trying to say just as a man just listen
to it from from from our point of view
if you never heard it like this before
just just listen and just take it on
board a little bit that's all can I ask
you a question
sorry I don't know your name so you see
over the last 10 years when you've been
in those situation ships whatever they
were one just one yeah so it's just one
in the last two years one person and how
long did it last it lasted four years
and at any time during that situation
did you want him to be a boyfriend at
this
at this and then I didn't want him to be
my
okay so well two questions firstly what
happened at the start that didn't make
it become a relationship and secondly
why did he not why did you afterwards
not want him to be a boyfriend I was in
a vulnerable state my mom passed away
and I felt like I didn't have any Woody
so um the person that wanted me I was
okay with doing
the sexing
um I did want him to be my boyfriend at
first I felt like that was the direction
we was going realized it wasn't
understood what I could still get from
him
and after a while once I was done I'd be
both parted our ways
okay
but if he had wanted to be your
boyfriend during that time it would have
been a relationship right he asked me to
be his girlfriend I told him no when did
he ask you to be his girlfriend
um yeah before I broke everything off
okay fair enough but I guess it's almost
like when you got what you wanted you
didn't want it anymore
um I understood the person that I was
sleeping with and I didn't want to be in
a relationship with him but I was okay
with doing what we was doing from the
start
okay
so you carried on sleeping with him
after you realized that there was no
yeah
I didn't want to sleep around I wanted
to stay with the same person
okay fine yeah I hear girls say they do
that a lot but I guess in terms of the
relationship itself or the situation
itself I think it still stands that with
guys if he'd wanted a relationship at
the beginning you would have had a
relationship I guess you know the fact
that he didn't want a relationship at
the beginning might have been why you
didn't want it afterwards but it still
kind of stays consistent with the point
that if a guy once shows interest that
he wants to have a relationship that's
really the deciding fact of a lot of
cases
um when it comes to actually having sex
it's more the girl that makes that
decided decision so you know I think
when we look at someone who hasn't had a
relationship for a certain amount of
time we normally work on the basis that
that's because the guy didn't want it um
I feel like he didn't want it and then
he did so I don't think I was in my head
about it in a way where like I want to
be in a relationship it was very much
like I like you you like me this is what
we're doing why can't we be and then he
explained himself and then I felt a type
of way but understood maybe I wasn't
ready to be in a relationship after my
vulnerable state after going through
therapy I understood that this isn't
something that I wanted life long term
it wasn't something that I wanted to
endure have kids marry with him but I
knew it was something I needed to stop
so I eventually did was he really good
looking
he was alive I'm gonna say like his trim
was a bit it's a bit did she know him
yeah yeah was he good looking would you
say
was he tall how tall was he no it's like
mine's high like five six five seven
five six five seven five seven okay
usually I just find that usually like if
if a girl like it's usually looks if a
girl doesn't want it I wish it was it
might have been a bit easier if it was
about looks
sorry guys um also these two are X's by
the way yeah oh yeah
boom
what he was my first boyfriend after him
I never was with anybody no no hold on
hold on a second hold on yeah yeah
is is he who you were just talking about
no he's my first boyfriend ever but they
lost everything he is the first of
everything so why didn't that work out
ask him
you dump her or did she dump you I did
but it's just because like my head was
everywhere at the time I was a young boy
how old were you
[Laughter]
I agree it wouldn't be good for him
we've turned out to be really really
good friends and I appreciate that one
literally a thing anymore this is crazy
I was not expected surprise
everyone
I didn't know if you guys were going to
tell me yeah I didn't I didn't know if I
should I was like it's getting like kind
of smoke okay if she she gets married
someday are you I would go that's fine
she's in my bridge what do you mean you
you'd go to the wedding if I was invited
I mean what if one of her her new man
said oh so what if your new man said
like this guy has all the things you
look for yeah you know if you pass up on
him it's like that you're not getting
better it's just not happening and
he says I don't do guy friends I don't I
don't date girls that don't have guy
friends if you want to be with me but
I'm looking for a wife I'm looking for a
wife and if you want to be with me I
don't I don't date girls with guy
friends what you doing let me interject
tonight
she's being messy
um
that's hard because the guy that I love
would never say that to me but and it's
moment I'll answer it because it will be
a black and white moment it's a yeah
okay I would say
yeah because he shouldn't ever make me
feel like there was an ultimatum to
invite somebody up no longer than him
it's a standard
see this is like every time guys have a
standard I don't think you're doing it
intentionally but you kind of you kind
of Shame them for doing it so if a guy
says like I don't I don't want to date a
girl with a bunch of guy friends hanging
around I don't want to date a girl that
goes to the club you're like oh why
would you do that like that's that's
controlling if it's not controlling it's
a standard I didn't look I'm new to this
I'm so sorry it feels the other way
around and you're the guy has his ex as
his close friend how are you feeling
like that because
I feel like it's okay it always depends
on the situation because if you look at
us for example like there hasn't been
any sexual history in like 10 years it's
been a long time but there's been sexual
history it has yeah but it's been such a
long time so but if you if like when she
was seeing the other guy me and him was
cool I used to go around to the house
and chill with the ball for them it was
no problem he felt no type of way that I
was there she met because
she met the mother of my child that
can't happen that can't happen I've met
his child this is this is all types of
disrespect this is all types of ancestry
this is awesome
so so it's because we was friends before
we got into a relationship and then
after we realized that we can't be in a
relationship so we were friends when we
were babies our moms used to make us do
play dates this is getting worse
no like what you guys have done is you
guys should have just got it together
instead you guys have played games going
into the world and you still kept this
connection you didn't want me he didn't
want me and that makes it even worse
because he got rid of you see as a man
this is giving me all types of red flags
so the first so the first thing I'm
going to say you should ask him though
like no we'll get we'll get to it okay
but the first thing I want to say as a
man is as a man is you if you've got a
potential husband or boyfriend and he
said to you I'm not comfortable with
with male friends around you and if you
use that as a thing to label him as
insecure I was controlling no no but I'm
I'm saying if you consider it as as a
problem then you really don't know what
it is to be loved by a man no no no no I
mean it's really sad do you really feel
like that 100 because I really mean yeah
listen listen oh my god listen I'm sorry
no don't be sorry just don't be
disrespectful that's disrespectful yes
it's very disrespectful ah listen listen
I'm teaching you something I'm teaching
you something okay I'm teaching you
something because when you get a man
that actually wants you and you speak
like this he's gonna go straight away
because for me this is a red flag I've
got a girl and
um there's no way she could be having a
barrage of male friends around her yes
you can she can know males and they had
them before in their life and what have
you not but once I'm on the scene no
men's can be calling her phone she can't
be saying I'm going to be out with some
with some guy friends if we're out and
male friends see her she needs to do
that and to keep them on the other side
you know why because
that means all your male friends gotta
go you know every person that you know
every person that you know God will come
out because it's disrespectful if you
outside and you have five or six
different men that come to hug you in
front of your man that's a very big
problem so you can just you know I mean
because if I saw you with your man and
he was my friend I would do that I would
know respectfully not to come over there
and to start hugging you up in front of
your man even if they doc Bridges it's
about respect but and boundaries like
guys like you have to understand like
respect to man is love like men don't
feel loved if they don't feel respected
and in your job as a woman is to make
them look good and this goes back to
does it does it look good to a guy to
have his girl hugging the whole football
team hugging the whole basketball team
hugging hugging the whole rap scene but
I think I'm sorry to cut you but I feel
like you guys have the wrong picture of
our friendship honestly because it what
you are saying I would I understand
because personally if I was if I started
seeing a girl and she told me that she
has this really close friend now she had
history with her obviously I'm always
going to feel naturally wait pause pause
I'm always going to feel some type of
way about it however when the guy comes
into the picture and and she's seeing
the guy I will make him feel comfortable
because I'm not trying to cause no
situations because I respect her and I
respect the fact that she's now found a
new person and she's the same with me we
don't make each other's new counterparts
feel some type of way because we have
history and our history again is such a
long time ago that now it's like
your business you're missing a point
though what if he says he's not
comfortable despite if he says he's not
comfortable to his girlfriend then I
would walk away yeah yeah it's not your
decision though it's his girlfriend's
decision right now his girlfriend has
just said that she wouldn't listen to
what he's saying and and that's a big
problem for a guy that's a very huge
problem so I would respect it to a
certain no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
it is black and white so so listen to
this and this is why I say women love
love the streets so much because because
you have a man that's prepared to to to
marry you he's prepared to literally
take you on as his wife all the things
you've been talking about for the last
10 years you haven't had and the simple
thing it says is you've got an X that
used to blow your back out I don't want
them around you no more like no no but
this is how men think you want me to
talk about how this is how we think we
think some okay this is how some men
think but the types of men you are
attracted to think like that because if
not you would have picked one of these
guys in your comments on your DMs for
years I've won it uh nasty that's
desperate I would never see you're doing
it again you haven't given them a chance
because these are the guys you do you
don't see you don't see these guys but
the guys you do see are the ones that
speak like this and think like this I'm
being honest with you and if you want to
look at it look at it as this is new
information you've never heard before
take it in those new information
unless you're willing to go for the guys
which you'd never look at these are the
guys which will let you have him as a
friend because they've been trying to
try to take you out for years and they
want to see you the types of guys that
meet you and it and they speak like me
they will never allow him to be your
friend they'll just say look that's your
boy you can if you see him that's cool
but all of that stuff cuts off now that
I'm involved I think the bigger issue is
that he might be cool with it he might
not but the whole point is that his girl
won't listen to him facts that's the big
problem right there as far as I'm
concerned you know he might be cool he
might meet the guy and say yeah you know
I respect your relationship but if he
turns around and says I'm not
comfortable with it and the girlfriend
turns around and says she's not going to
listen to him she doesn't respect him
and she doesn't value the relationship
enough you know that's that's the
message the moment a girl says that to
me bro I can't lie like yeah she's
single man yeah so what you are saying
yeah basically that if your girl said
that she had a friend that is an ex but
she would like to bring him around you
though you would feel some type of way
because me personally if my girl that
I'm seeing said that she has a friend
and she doesn't mind bringing me around
him then it's like it proves to me that
there's not really nothing to hide what
it proves because yeah because that
you're around me 24 like me I like my
girl to be around me 24 7. so if she now
then brings the like they're not there
I'm not expecting them to be close
because me and I don't speak every
single day and I'm falling in her 24 7
because that's how you are making it
seem no but you're fighting for it like
you do that if this is just a thing
where so for example if you guys were
friends and you might occasionally bump
into each other and you know you know
maybe a family barbecue or something we
don't even have to have this
conversation but the conversation you
guys are giving me is the one where you
know what you know we played in the
sandpit together we dated for this with
our family's still closed you know
that's my I'm like hold on a second why
did you get with him then and just fix
it like I don't know what I'm here for
that's really sad it's not sad it is
because why can't it be a thing where I
respect his mum enough to call her
auntie and go over for some jollof and
and have a good time with the family
because I don't have my mum in the
picture but you have a man who you're
supposed to be building that
relationship with and that's still fine
I believe in him and I and I will
definitely go through that Journey but
to think I'm disrespecting my husband
because I'm friends with a man but I
think it's not that you're friends with
a man the point is you're not listening
to him like again love to man is respect
it's saying you know what I might not
agree with this but I respect your
judgment so I'm gonna go with it I'm
gonna do what you say but like men don't
want an argumentative woman and what
you're doing is why wouldn't you're not
listening to me you keep trying to say
but but you're actually not listening to
me men and women are fundamentally
different we look at cheating
differently by the way you're acting and
what you're saying to me we classify
that as cheating you know no but you
have to listen to it you don't have to
I'm listening so I just don't agree so
it seems like I'm not listening no but
you don't see not agreeing is that part
where you're going to kick back men are
not going to change and the types of men
that will allow you to do this you do
not check for you don't look at you see
past the invisible to you so the types
of men that will allow this to happen
you do not check for so what I'm saying
as a man and what this other gentleman
is saying as a man is that if you if
we're taking all my misses and I'm
serious about you yeah and I want to
introduce you to my family I want to
marry you if you cannot do something
like this to go into then it's fine but
this is what I say modern women are for
the streets and they want to stay in the
streets because when you've got a man
that is all you want to show is that a
bit of commitment from you you're like
no no no no no the Rave is so important
I'm going out my girls
but that seems a little bit far-fetched
because nobody said I'm going out no
matter what you said or I'm gonna go and
see him but it's when we asked you the
question if when we we asked you if he
said this what would you do yeah and you
said no I would still do what I'm gonna
do okay no I that's that's not agreeable
that's that's not feminine that's
argumentative okay
and I like you I think I think you know
what it is you you remind me of a lot of
women that I've met and I've dealt with
and like you looked apart I look the
part what do you mean by that what do
you mean you're very you look very
feminine okay yeah you look very
feminine in your you know I mean you're
made well you presented very well so you
look very feminine and when you talk you
have a nice tone of voice but when we
say certain things as soon as we say I
get to see your eyes start rolling back
and you want to kick back with it but
but what are you really kicking back for
like um do you know what I've never
heard these point of views and it's good
to be open about these kind of
conversations I do how old are your
brothers they are 24.
um they're twins shout out to twin
brothers so have you ever spoke your
brothers about relationships yeah and
what do they say they have their
different twins we're sisters yeah they
have
um are you guys are sisters yeah there's
a hole
I was wondering I was like oh they must
have been friends for a while she's my
sister I guess they have their own
different views on relationships
but when you say what what do they think
what do you mean by that like obviously
okay so you're there yeah older sister
so obviously they're slightly um they're
slightly Junior to you you're still
quite young so a lot of the times is
brothers would would speak to their
sisters but they're young they're
younger so obviously so you're older
them my thing is this I don't know
obviously your relationship with your
father like I don't know any of those
types of stuff but I tend to think that
a lot of times girls I've had friends
that are man and they totally speak to
them at least one or two guys will be
real and be like yo this is what it is
like like so when you have a real guy
that's real that he should be saying to
you everything I'm saying is it's not
some it's not some fallacy it's not some
idea that that I've just just created
out my my head a lot of men will lie as
you said they're not going to care about
body count you know why because they're
not gonna be around long enough to care
about it they're going to run it up and
give it to your husband he's the one
that's going to care about it so when
Mana when you're saying oh I've never
heard this before is because why would
they say it men never speak about so how
are women supposed to learn about it if
you don't see it
because okay more men need to tell the
truth that's that's really what it is
and there should be a father in the home
but a lot of like women weren't raised
by wives and they don't have a dad in
the home so they have no one to teach
them I was I'm not saying you I'm sorry
sorry I don't know anyone's backstory
here but I'm just saying in general like
your dads are supposed to teach you this
stuff
okay
and your brothers I mean I don't have
all the same views as her so so what so
so your sisters um so what do you think
um I I kind of agree with what you're
saying but only because I know the
relationship like the friendship between
them I would understand why it would be
hard for her to just like kick him to
the side for a man who possibly could be
gone one day whereas he's probably never
going to live her life and also just to
say if the guy did have a problem with
me being in a situation I would be happy
taking a step back yeah but they're
saying you're not good no bro you're not
the problem no it's not yours yeah I'll
be disrespectful I hear that yeah yeah
like so yeah it's not you it just comes
down to um comes down to the to the
woman's decision and the willingness to
get like put that aside for to make him
happening I'll be honest a lot of times
men don't we don't even kiss
oh sorry A lot of times man we don't
even care we just want to know you would
do it we just ask you and then soon your
first answer is the answer that lets us
know and when we start kicking back it's
like it's like if you're gonna wear
something out I love the fact that my
girl's gonna send me what she's wearing
now I can pick or do you think do you
think this is too much too much skin if
I say that she's gonna change it not
because not because I'm trying to stop
her from wearing something no I'm just
like oh maybe that was a little bit you
know I'm trying to say like you're
giving a bit too much of what you should
have been given all right cool you know
what I'm saying yeah
um and maybe we'd like to be a part of
the process we're not stopping you we
see you can go out but when you start
going out too much or if you start going
out with single friends or potentially
you're going to places where you know
maybe the vibe isn't right or what
they've hurt they claiming drama or
things have happened in the past that's
when we get worried you know I'm trying
to say to you but we're not trying to
stop a woman from ever going out but
we'll get concerned when you start going
up too much and you put yourself in
situations where men can start hitting
up to you and then there's alcohol
flowing and and and you know whenever
people say I made a mistake or I was
drunk that's never happened when someone
wasn't drunk and they didn't make a
mistake so you have to take a lot of
these scenarios out and we know women
cheat as much as men do so there has to
be someone doing the cheating and if we
talk about women having women are the
ones with the gateway gateway sorry The
Gatekeepers the sex then once you're
adding nightclub what you're adding out
with a single whole friends watch out
once you're adding alcohol once you add
in all of these other factors and the
fact that you can make a mistake well
human how about we just try to just take
away some of these factors that's all
I'm saying
respectfully
that's fair enough
so
every question
felons have 30 percent more kids over
their lifetimes than non-felons
why do modern women love bad boys
I can't answer that one
um I can also put my perspective I feel
like
like we like bad boys because we feel
like we want to feel protected and
but I mean but what makes you feel like
a good guy can't protect you no it's not
that it's not that they can't it's just
I haven't seen that they can whereas
with like bad boys you kind of like
know what they're on so like kind of so
so sorry carry on but I want to ask you
something so do you feel it's a man's
job to protect you always yeah that's
cool no that's cool well I do my dad
protects me so I feel like when my man
should do it yeah that's cool that's
what I feel that's that's that's what we
prescribe to you but there seems to be
something that goes on when we talk when
we speak like this there seems to be a
different narrative that gets pushed
about how we speak about wanting to
protect women and and be there so when I
heard you say
protect that's one of the things that we
always talk about so I just picked up on
him carry on
um yeah that's only that's why I would
rather
yeah do most of your friends like the
nice guys or the Bad Boys
um most of my friends
they like bad boys as well what about
what about each other what are what are
each other's types
I just don't want somebody to make me
feel like I gotta back us up and you
ain't doing nothing
you know what I'm saying no no okay I
don't want to feel like I'm in a
situation where
um a man is being disrespectful maybe I
mean maybe I'm out with my with my
fiance and we're out to dinner and maybe
somebody's being really disrespectful on
the table
um next to us I don't want to feel like
I'm going back and forth with this
person and you're just sitting there
watching us go back and forth I don't
want to feel like I'm not protected that
way so so you do like the bad boys a
little bit not it doesn't necessarily
have to be bad it just has to be
he knows how to make me feel safe it
doesn't have to be bad though okay
that's cap I'm both of their friends and
they both like Batman
I don't like the guy is he a bad boy is
he a bad boy you know who I'm talking
about is he a bad boy is he got time to
be a bad boy no seriously no he might
not be a bad boy now previously man man
that other men better than women do let
him talk I'm telling you like they're
lying they both like bad boys
she's lying she likes Bad Boys
do you know what is it's not that she's
lying guys yeah it's
she believes that that's not what she
likes but it is what she likes
Pearl you know what I found interesting
I don't think she does I feel like deep
down like we know we just don't like to
admit it yeah so she believes that she
doesn't like them but she does and so
and so then later when we get bamboozled
we're like oh no he cheated I can't
believe it and it's like come on one
more time for these guys if they told me
they're seeing someone I can just assess
the situation and know what's gonna
happen but obviously I can't say because
then I'm just being negative so what
about my situation no I told you about
that already tell us
I don't want to answer it on camera
because obviously he might be watching
right now and I don't want to you know
be ready said enough stuff
you know what I've really got the gist
of it you know what you know I find it
interesting yeah you know I find it
interesting you both mentioned talked
about being protected but then when we
spoke about you going to certain places
and putting yourself in certain dangers
about putting you wasn't worried about
being protected then so uh
I don't go clubbing Festival okay I go
out for drinks yes and I go like places
with my friends but for instance if my
man didn't want like I go out because I
work
Sunday to Thursday and I'm stuck in a
house from Sunday to Thursday can't
leave so on the weekend I like to go out
and let my hair down but if I had a
partner and he didn't want me to go out
with my friends I'd go out with him like
yeah okay so we're gonna we're gonna
move that yeah but the reason why I say
is because you spoke about protection I
don't want to be out in a restaurant and
a man says something and he can't handle
it and that's perfectly fine but now you
what now you listen now you're now
you're starting to think how men think I
don't want my girl to be out in a club
or something and something happens and
I'm not there to protect her so see a
lot of things that men think about with
mitigate and we see dangers a lot of
dangers you may not see and it's the
part of of you know loving loving loving
your family loving your girl have
sisters and and I've had relationships
where your girl's gonna go outside and
then something's going to happen and you
know now you get the call and upset girl
now you have to come outside you might
be giving your bridge on a call now he
has to come outside now so when we step
outside now two things can happen uh
well more than two things can happen but
now I'm putting my safety at Jeopardy
because I'm about to go into scenario
which I don't know because something
could have happened happened to you and
on top of that I'm putting my
potentially putting my freedom on the
line as well so these are two scenarios
that have happened all because
potentially you went to somewhere where
you didn't have to go and that's not
stopping you from going out it's just
when we say when I'm when your man asks
you certain things this is these are the
things that we think of so you already
likened it to being at a restaurant and
um my man's there to protect me in case
someone disrespects me but if your man's
not there this is how we think what if
someone disrespects her then so I just
want you to think about that a little
bit after that point sorry as well is
that you have the expectation for the
man to protect you that's got to be a
man that you listen to Because Why is a
guy gonna be willing to do all of these
things to protect someone that when he
says something she won't even listen to
him you know what I mean it's like
having your cake and eating it
and the guy is willing to do a lot more
for a girl that he knows will listen to
him when he says that you know facts
like anything like if you like like
there's so much power and femininity
like you know how mad it is like you
women sometimes don't understand how
much power that you have like just by
listening and just by actually just
saying you know actually I agree oh
you're like oh she listens to me oh oh
she's a winner let me go and do
something nice for her just something as
simple as that
but instead you want to back you want to
battle am I like oh not actually gonna
go cheat on her not joking
okay I'm going to take a second to read
super chats
um guys make sure you like the video the
like is the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these streams
so make sure you like the video also
guys we are trying to get to
500 000 subscribers which is not so I
mean we've been doing the show what like
six seven months like we're almost to
500k come on come on
um also sorry guys my laptop's being
weird
um also don't forget to leave a comment
on the stream and let me know what
topics you'd like us to see next week
and a reminder that the top um the top
Super chat today gets to have something
on the board tomorrow um I think we're
gonna do it a little further back so you
can see it better but we'll have your
username and then whatever you want as
the title
so um let's go um see sir deck
um it's not that she's lying it's not
that she's lying because she believes
the it's not that she's lying it's
because she believes the lie your honor
the prosecution rests
um leather skirt has never heard these
views proof of feminism programming the
media saturated saturated
saturated with it brainwashing the
masses this is why shows like this are
so important and get so much push back
zentian Simpsons are males who lack a
spine character and conviction to
actually go after the woman they want
while allowing a friend to come over to
their mother's house I smell three
vaginas on the sofa I see him as an
up-and-coming Will Smith or Derek Jack
um Professor Trill you're willing to
give up a man that wants you for a man
that doesn't want you make it make sense
hashtag female Logic sentience the hoe
and the corset will find out that men
will quietly Place her in the rubbish
category because she is strong and
independent the man she's with no she's
not wife material and will just get his
nut off but never wife her no man worth
his Stones is Eskimo or tunnel buddies
with any of his mates any woman who has
male friends or social media and has
means and motivation to cheat she's
automatically in the use and reuse
category no high value men will tolerate
disrespect vanity Rose
the fact that it was a long time ago
doesn't matter pack has been dead for
Going on 30 years and Jada's still
tossing and turning for him even Willow
writes pack love letters
um Voodoo key it's funny 20 years ago
women were shouting for men to not sleep
around and pick a woman because they
wanted to feel special now men are the
ones saying this to women and they can't
comprehend it Nate Davis love your
content Pearl keep doing what you're
doing that's a 69.99 cad Super Chat
that's the biggest Super Chat on the
stream so far so
um you know if you guys want to be on
the board next week let me know oh wait
I'm gonna be gone it'll be when I get
back it'll be when I get back okay Mall
um first of all it's come all second of
all Super Chat is is a per Precision
engineered to make Pearl say ho ho you
fat um oblasky akinka don't wipe the 304
if you do she was she will go to her
natural habitat the street
um katho Swiss um YouTube is censoring
what I want to say so here's five
dollars
um vanity Rose man being celebrated for
high body counts as BS 20 out of 100 are
the only ones getting action do you
seriously think the other 80 on the side
are depressed and lonely are cheering
them on Bernard Schmidt what I would
have given Second Chances but woman
never gave me a first chance
um Andre once you're at 304 you won't be
able to go back to being a faithful wife
the 304 always comes back up again men
don't need that be a 304 if you want but
understand there is a price to pay
Reuben Padilla you should watch the
YouTuber McQueen he goes picking girls
acting and using Andrew Tate lines he
has so many numbers
that's all the super chats guys don't
forget to like the video on your way in
so I asked this question earlier
how to the guys
would you rather date a girl that has
let's say 75 bodies
or a child
but how much bloodies does the girl of
the child have
let's say low five
three three two and two
probably the girl with the child but
it's still awkward at the same time but
yeah
okay wait do I know any of these 75
buddies
um let's say it's 75 you gotta know one
you gotta know one
75 bodies man 75 bodies over a child
yeah every time
definitely the child because today the
amount girls demand from boys they get
boys to work hard like anything and they
hardly even give a child and they part
up very quickly if boys don't work hard
and earn an amount
so so you would date the woman with the
child over 75. yeah and today many times
that the basic benefit for a boy to
marry a girl is just pushing on
generation
there's hardly any other benefit of
marriage today there isn't that's why
parenting people get married if you look
at our generation for me I'd say I would
choose the girl with a child because
the woman who's got 75 bodies is less
valuable it's like I don't want her
because now everybody wants her or
everybody's had hers yeah but you can
put her to the side yeah but really
reality someone has got a child is
actually less valuable because they've
already given the highest order they can
give to a man by pushing out someone
else's child and so you might see it
different because you've got a child but
so a man like me like there's no I get
no benefit from coming in and bringing
up another man's child another man's
there's no benefit for me at all I can't
pass on my seeds like that it's not my
so have you ever dated a girl that's got
a child before it doesn't sound like you
have no but uh no I've I've slept with
my children don't know that's not the
question I asked have you ever dated a
girl that's got a child no but I
wouldn't why because men don't men don't
finish up immense games
the truth for the matter like end of the
day you're gonna see something
differently because you've got a child
but myself I've got to a good age and
I'm with no children my friend over
there as well go to a good age with no
children there's some responsibility you
need to have so I think ever when we
grew up we were told that you know if
you went out there we had a child out of
wedlock would be a lot harder for you
um so we knew that there seemed to be
something now they're trying to push
being a stepdad is some type of good
thing that men should do and it's an
honor it's not an honor it's a big
disrespect for us because we get a
continuous reminder that we were not the
first choice that as far as I'm
concerned both of you women are virgins
the only way I know you're not a virgin
is when you come with a child and that's
how the world looks at it so there's no
benefits for us man
why do you feel that it's so good
otherwise how do we progress Our
Generation
no that's not my job married the guy
before she should have married like
she's saying he wants to have a kid with
a girl he doesn't want to raise someone
else's kid
he comes down to poor decision making
again as well you know and I think a lot
of you know what you know what really
annoys me I'll tell you what annoys me
is meeting women outside the nightclub
with newly born kids on like one year
old and they're looking for a new man I
just do not understand it you you you
push that a whole man's kid that you
have no idea that you that you don't
want to be with now you're outside
looking for a new man and you really
think like you're going to get a good
quality man no you're just gonna get
dates and get your back blown out so I'm
saying to you that's all you're gonna
get because Society has lied to you made
you think that you can go and get high
and typically you don't get higher than
your baby dad so whatever your baby dad
is when women are cussing their baby dad
we look at you and say oh but you bread
from that man like and now you're trying
to come to me and you want me to come
and pick up the mess so for example let
me say something to you if I meet you
and you've got one child
if I want to
um get married to a woman movie I want
to get a place for us
um if we started a one bedroom might
have been enough because the start even
a two-bedroom cool but I have to think
about your child so when I want to have
my own child we need to actually have a
three bedroom it's already costing me so
if I want to send my children to school
you know I want to sell my truck my
child to private school can I send my
child to private school and send your
kid to the local comprehensive will you
like that if if I want to buy my child
for his for example Jordans but you'll
try to watch trainers I'm like no I'm
gonna buy them high tech is that okay
with you if we go out if we go out for
example to to the fun fair to Thorpe
Park Alton Towers
um my child wants to get ice cream wants
to get some you know wants to get some
teddies and I buy them and then your
child says then you can have someone
said no go and call your dad and pay for
him are you going to be okay with that
the fact remains is these charts are
going to be a cost for us women don't
look it like that but men we see it like
that so there's no benefits of of me
raising your child other than the ones
that you will see fit can I discipline
your child the way I want to can I hit
your child if I want to you might not
see hitting your child but I may want to
do that can I do that in the future if
you have a female daughter in the future
she gets old enough and she makes an
accusation against me are you going to
treat me like a father or are you going
to treat me as someone these are all
things that men mitigate and think to
and because you don't think as far as
head you don't realize why it's so
dangerous and it's and it's and it's not
worth us being stepdads
boom
what do you guys think of that
the truth
I'm sorry you too you seem shocked I
don't know
or does that make sense to you I don't
know how to feel simply because
I have a stepdad which is her dad yeah
my dad raised her from the age so if I
didn't get a father figure in life I
might have not understood the way that I
think to this day and it wasn't
necessarily have to mean me being in a
relationship but like maybe just simple
things in life or like how I can look at
life or like my beliefs in Life or like
how to be open-minded who I am as a
black woman if I didn't get those
certain things could I just hope that my
mom was gonna give me all of that and
also odd dad treats us the same yeah he
doesn't differentiate if if I get she
gets if she gets I get well I think
that's also representative of your
mother so your mom's recognize this
man's gonna be a stepdad and she's going
to treat him like probably like we have
different different moms okay wait so
yeah complicated our younger siblings
have so I am the same dad as our younger
siblings and she has to say mum as I am
just a different Dad I'm the only one
with a different dad and I'm the only
one with a different one
so they both brought a kid into the
relationship yeah okay cool I understand
I understand
um but yeah but I'll still say the same
thing I think
before men was respected for being
stepdads like they were respected they
were seen as they were picking up
another man there was literally women
would be like oh my God I can't believe
I'm getting mad these guys come but now
it's like yo they want they think being
a single mother is like empowering and
it's something to be proud of I'm like
girl like you can't even keep the man
that you bred from like we don't respect
that over here and when we say it loud
it sounds like it sounds mad because men
don't say this because they're not going
to stay around long enough they're just
gonna hit it and keep it moving I think
there's also correlation between that
and uh um promiscuous behavior of women
as well because you know we were talking
about hoes before when you sleep around
indiscriminately and you're not really
trying to filter out who you got a
connection with who you see something
long time with that's when you're more
likely to end up being a single mum
because you're having sex with a guy
that probably you got no future with and
then you just end up with this kid
so I think there's a lot of that going
on as well how these women end up single
moms well and and the problem is it's a
lot bigger liability nowadays to become
a stepfather because one like if she
leaves you have no rights to that child
so you could raise a kid for 10 years
and you could never see that child again
and then on top of that like if you get
married to her and you get divorced like
she can take half
and put and put and put you on child
support if you have more kids
I mean and women and women leave 70 to
80 percent of the time 90 of their
college educated oh no
yeah it we're the ones a lot of times
women are afraid of being left but we're
the ones leaving
[Music]
does that surprise you not really no no
do you think that's normal with like
what you've seen yeah definitely
from what my I've seen in my lifetime I
feel like um
like my mom was with
our dad for a while and then she ended
up doing the independent thing and like
doing it herself but I don't know I just
feel like they
they understood each other but they were
two different people at the same time of
what they wanted to achieve out of life
did she get remarried no my mom was
never married actually do you do you
think she was happier when she was in a
relationship or out of it
in it you know I don't think she would
have wanted to admit that but yeah yeah
she had happy times when she was single
too but I think just being a family as a
whole would just make any woman or any
couple happy mm-hmm
what um does that like
do you feel like having that model
growing up like was it did it help you
with men or no no
um
I respect him I love him as a father
figure definitely but there's always
going to be that I'm not really chosen
kind of feeling because he's not really
my biological dad and there's not
nothing against him it's just how I feel
um maybe a lot of people or kids when
they're in mixed or Blended families
probably feel that way too but
I mean it's not therefore they do the
best that they can how I feel is just
how I feel based on
how I would like my family to be I guess
like I would love my dad to still be in
the picture but that's not necessarily
the case
um
I know who my dad is but we don't have a
relationship at all
do you feel like having your dad in the
picture would have helped you like vet
guys better I don't know because now I
know who my dad is I don't think he
would have really made a difference
just being honest you know what what I
get from this is just even listening to
you and I and I feel for you in a way
but I feel for your stepdad because just
listen like imagine a stepdad that hears
this no he stepped in he's done as best
he can he does all of these things but
yet you still just feel like for some
reason that I just don't belong even
though he's trying to make you belong
obviously he's obviously I feel like
nobody would understand unless they're
in that City no no no but I I know I
hate you I hate you I'm just saying like
it it probably would hurt him and it's
nothing new that I haven't not said to
him before but once again when I talk
about not wanting to be a stepdad just
look at what you just gave me you gave
me I can bring you up I can come in I
can do all these things but you're still
not gonna see me as your dad but I don't
know if it would have made a difference
if I had a relationship with my dad too
if that makes any sense yeah I hear that
but now we don't know about that but the
one the one thing we do know you did
have a man father figure in your life
and he was constantly he was there and
he taught me a lot and he taught you a
lot but you still have a feeling of this
is not an incomplete feeling yeah and
this is why I say it's important for us
to threat the relationships and we stay
and keep our families together because
one of the biggest things that I've seen
is that my mum and dad have been
together through freaking Finn and it's
been the basis of how I see my life and
relationships and when women don't
prescribe to that I automatically know
this is not someone I want to be with
because of what I've been brought up to
well let me not make it seem like that
no because no because I do want to make
sure that we're showing appreciation for
somebody that actually did make a
difference in my life because if he
wasn't in my life I don't know who I
would actually be today I'm not gonna
make it seem like that because the
conversations that I've had the things
that he's taught me the books that he's
told me to read me making music and
wanting to do more about my Artistry
that was down to him but the inside
feeling I don't know how to explain it
it's an incomplete feeling of knowing
that my dad didn't want my dad didn't
want nothing to do with me but one of
the things that I think is important to
that is that people always talk about
how easy is to go get another man to
just step in like but they don't speak
to the children that have stepped that
have actually grown up in these things
where they never had their dad or and a
lot of times I've spoken to a lot of my
friends and I see it all the all the
hurt and all the trauma that that's been
caused from just women saying oh yeah
pick a next man or your dad can't be in
there like people need to there's
something about identity and the reason
I have such a strong sense of identity
is because I have my history and my
roots back through my Village I go back
there I know my grandfather I know all
the history back through the walls and
that puts you a sense of identity and so
when you step into the world and then
you meet all these people that just have
all these broken ideas of how things
should be it's it look it makes it sound
like you're some anomaly or some crazy
person but you're actually not and no
I'm not but I think it's also as much as
we all want things to be a type of way
and that goes with culture as well as
religion I'm not gonna try and act like
my life was a complete blow over because
I had a stepfather in my life and I
didn't have my dad in my life like I'm
still grateful for everything that I've
got because I'm still here I could have
drank the like I could have done a lot
ages ago but that's not the case I feel
like it is still a normality when it
comes to Blended families I feel like if
like it might not necessarily have to be
a dad it could be a woman Inside the
inside the picture too do you think we
should make Blended families normal or
try to have women better vet them and
they sleep with in a family stay
together I feel like both because you do
need to know who you're sleeping with
but at the same time if you've like gone
and done what you've did how do we move
forward are we just going to keep
looking back at like where it all went
wrong and some people they don't they
notice afterwards having kids I I know
like obviously like what what are the
women with children gonna do like that
like what else can they do other than
try to move forward but I'm saying for
the Next Generation do you know you
don't think it's better to push them to
keep families together yeah and I think
that's the only point he's trying to
make no and I agree it's not to diminish
what like he sounds like a great man
like it's not to diminish anything he
did I was saying it for myself sake yeah
yeah it's just for like the Next
Generation we should probably push for
families to stay together and as like
the Next Generation or looking at it in
a way where I've seen my mom being
Blended families and like how it worked
out for her not in that way but I
personally would like to be in a family
where
this is my man this is my kids this is
our us as a family it's not like divorce
would never be an option so I'm like the
next example I guess do you feel like
the men that you pick are would make
good husbands and fathers the ones I've
done previously no the one I'm speaking
to now yeah yeah but what about actually
I don't want to get him in trouble
no go ahead beat freely like what what
do you do you agree he'd make a good
husband good father
do you even remember his name
yeah that's what I'm saying yeah oh yeah
you guys are awesome yeah and I and I
said I don't want to get you in trouble
and then you said speak freely sorry I
missed the question completely
um obviously
although I've heard of this guy is he's
a good guy he works he does his thing
but obviously
I haven't met him personally he doesn't
live in this country in it so it's like
another jobs Max situation
[Laughter]
how many drop the matches
you know you don't have to answer if I
get it I'm just gonna ask you how did
you meet him it's a long story
if that makes you manage out or online
so you met him and then he moved
no he was on holiday yeah oh he was on
holiday
and and where is he now what country I'm
not gonna state that
is in Europe or is it like Africa
it's not in London no it's not in the
United Kingdom is it short haul or Long
Haul oh sure
the country without saying where okay
United States
Americans will get you there's an accent
it's not it's him
this is what I said at the beginning I
have my thoughts and obviously I I can't
say too much more on the topic yeah you
can't listen the reason I say it's just
interesting because a lot of time and
it's not just you it's really common but
like it's a lot of times as women we say
we want one thing but our actions
dictate that we don't because it's like
even how would that work out if you
really want a family I would have to
move I would want to move I've never
looked at my life like I'm gonna stay
here for the rest of my life to be
honest with you I've always found
interest with people that aren't from
here well it yeah it just doesn't seem
like a super good Prospect
maybe for some people look look this is
what I mean okay wait can I just can I
just say this
my best friend
is with somebody that is not from this
country and I promise you it's going
exactly the way that you thought it was
never gonna go does she have a ring
hey we can't disclose that right now you
can't disclose it that's how we judge
results she hasn't got she's got no
she's going together she hasn't got it
the ring is bought but she hasn't got it
yet but but I just think a lot of times
like as women we live in and
possibilities instead of probabilities
I'm here so it's like it's possible it's
definitely happening the reason why they
can't say is
no no no I'm talking about
um I I'm saying like like just because
you know one part it doesn't seem
probable it's possible but it doesn't
seem probable okay okay well I'm gonna
say yeah yeah is is you
see this is the bit where I was talking
about the decisions that women make and
and and
you're 28 you're about you are you see
that sign that says their thing Mitchell
the wall is undefeated you are at the
war now do you know what the wall do you
know do you know what the wall is no
please tell me Bill can you explain to
the wall please
yeah the wall is basically the part
where I would say roughly around eight
when a woman reaches age 30. so looks 28
is about to start yeah yeah it's about
the start of it but yeah but I think 30
is a typical Benchmark and that's when
her looks start to go downhill
her ability to attract men or the same
standard of men that she did when she
was in her prime which is usually sort
of late teens to mid-20s starts to
shrink and at that point her dating pool
obviously starts to shrink as well
um and really the goal for a lot of
women is to bag the guy
that she wants when she's in her prime
so I would say that at the age of 28
you're pretty much at that upper limit
towards the end of your best period to
be able to get the guy that you want
because what happens with a lot of women
right is during their Prime they'll have
a certain standard of guy and that's
what they're used to once they hit the
wall they still because you know it's
very hard for them to go down once
they've had a guy that meets a certain
type of criteria right so they end up in
this Perpetual cycle once they've hit
the wall where they still have these
high standards but they can't get that
guy anymore so yeah the aim of the game
is really to try and bag that guy and
commitment long-term commitment from
that guy before they hit the wall so I
think what what what this guy is
basically saying is that you haven't
really got much time and do you really
want to be using the
the latter stages of your Prime on
basically a long shot yeah I'll be
willing that so
um I'm just have some stuff that I've
written about the wall our primary
agency is our sexuality and how good we
look smv is a desirability to the
opposite sex 18 we
between the the wall is between the ages
of 18 and 28 or our primary agencies
between the ages of 18 and 28 when we
live to be 90. men between the ages of
20 and 70 rate 22 23 and 24 year olds as
the most attractive it's not an age but
a mindset it is the subconscious
acknowledgment that she cannot compete
in the same way she did when she was
younger
yeah so the reason I wanted to explain
it to you because I want to understand
that if you are 28 and you're without
you you don't have any children and I'm
trying to make you understand right now
that makes you high over here you know
what I'm saying we are respecting that
you don't have any children so remember
what we said we treat you as a virgin so
if a woman hasn't got any children we
don't know body count she's good to go
um for you to be to waste the next year
or two years and push you potentially to
29.30 for a guy that lives in the USA
when you already know geriatric
pregnancy starts and this whole thing
about about
um about freezing the eggs and IVF I
know people have done IVF have spent
over 50 Grand in IVF and they still
didn't work
um I have family members that spent a
lot of money and it didn't work in the
end God had to you know I mean you could
have to bust them if you you're not a
Kardashian so you won't be able to just
freeze your eggs so a lot of the options
that women think they have they're not
reserved for them they're reserved for
for people that have a lot of money that
can do these things on the top on top of
that these things don't guarantee any
results so I think
for you to be speaking to someone
potentially that would and stop you from
interacting with anyone else and then in
America I just I just I just unless a
man is telling you and he's literally
putting money into your account and
saying I'm setting up a life for you to
come I I suggest you start looking for
different options okay I've been real
with you yeah because because because if
I was your brother there's no way I'm
gonna be like so what you're holding out
for this guy over there no my sister
this is what we need to do and I don't
want to see you getting 30 30 and then
you're out in we are Festival looking
for man yeah to get me I don't I don't
it don't make sense no no because no
because I think you're a good case I
think you're a good case study I think
you're a woman no no I think I think a
woman that you said you know for 10
years you've been out the game
necessarily
um you know when we've spoken to you
what you want you want to you want a
complete family unit probably based on
some of the things that you've
experienced you're 28 you don't have any
child like and you know you honest you
had you had Therapies so you understand
some of the things you've gone through
you you're a candidate now for for a
good man but you need to listen to some
of the things that I've said so when
this good man comes you don't scare him
away with saying stuff like I won't
listen to you you know what I mean I
never said no but but what I'm trying to
say to you is this if you explained it
the way that you did afterwards about
like how men would feel when it comes to
women going out to the club like you
made it seem a little bit more different
I didn't I didn't I personally wasn't
looking at it the way that you explained
it like you you she he said it in more
in a secure way like it made it seem a
little bit more like okay I can
understand your point of view before it
was just like blunt like if I said you
can't go you can't go like oh well I
don't know you're talking to you
I didn't say it like that I didn't say
no but it came across that way to me
well well if you know for the for the
modern women out there that want to
learn to be wives and we're opening a
wife's School we're gonna bring in wives
from all over to teach teach modern
women how to cook clean
dancing and [ __ ] why cooking I clean can
I ask you a question though yeah so you
got this guy in America right let's say
you were to be out wherever and you met
a guy that was you know ticked all your
boxes and he was serious about trying to
get to know you
would you say no to him for the goddess
in America I've gone through that and
I've come right back to square one I've
done I've done that so somebody that I
saw as a potential so me as a potential
wanted to move forward
I don't know what happened but it didn't
go the way I wanted it to go to or the
way that he said it was going to go to
so I just left it for what it was and
then I rekindled what I have now going
on right now so was he a bad boy what
the guy that I used to talk yeah the one
the one over here no he was a good boy
um he was he was actually a good boy
yeah but I told her already with this
situation that she has over there I told
her
wait without waiting yeah like if that's
what you're gonna do then that's what
you're gonna do but don't expect yeah
see I want better results for for men
I'm a man so I want better results for
us but I want better results for women
so this thing when I said to you about
yo what Champion for women like it
sounds mad because men haven't spoken
like this but we have to get the
backlash on the corn for it we have to
get people chopping us up and making
edits and trying to make it change the
narrative we have to get this we have to
get our colleagues that said oh my God I
see oh your views are so misogyny we
have to get all of this but the reason
we get this because it's that vitally
important for us to get this message
across there's so many men that don't
have a voice there's so many men that
are scared to speak and more importantly
women are scared to speak so since I've
come on this my third time I've been on
here I did not think it would cause as
many Ruffles as it has right but I
understand why but what we need I get so
many women in my DMs that call me that
message me that's even in a few in the
comments that support what we're doing
but the problem is there's a minority of
of women that are speaking for the
majority and this minority is loud and
they are rude and they are crude and
they rep and they are now their voices
representing the larger um the law their
voice is represented for the majority
right so when we speak and then it
doesn't sound in the beginning we maybe
bump our heads a little bit but we
actually come to a place of where you
understand that actually you know what I
didn't think of it like this my mind's
got a point that's the point we need
women to to Jump by us and be like right
okay cool these guys are actually trying
to help people get better results
because by you understanding now or
automatically I know you're going to get
better results you're going to look at
yourself you're going to look at your
time you're going to think to yourself
it's all how you say it too because like
like I said the beginning from where we
was that's not what you sounded like to
where we are right now I feel like if
you sit down and talk to me I will
listen if I feel like you'll demanding
me and I don't understand what you're
saying to me I'm gonna be a bit like who
are you talking to you know no but it
was a hypothetical situation though
wasn't it because it came down to your
friendship with um with your friend
Aaron you were kind of just like no I
wouldn't listen so I guess we were just
giving how a man would perceive that you
know what I mean I also think you're
asking a men to communicate like women
and so and so you're asking men are very
blunt and they're very direct and
they're not really trying to think about
your feelings and be considered unless
they're more feminine typically within
and so and so when you say like you need
to communicate to me this way you're
basically saying be more like a woman I
don't feel like I'm saying that I feel I
don't think you mean to no I don't feel
like I'm saying that I feel like I'm I
don't think it's a problem for anybody
to be very
open and explain thoroughly about what
they're talking about because why is it
that you say JUMP I must I must jump
because men don't have the time to
explain every single decision that they
make and so it's like exhausting to them
so if you if he says hey can you do this
and you say why and then he has to have
a 10-minute conversation with you for
you to agree with it and now and now
you'll do it it's like that's exhausting
to a guy they would rather just have a
guy a girl that just says okay it's
because at that point I'm not that no at
that point that's what me yeah it goes
back to what we're saying about a woman
who a girlfriend a wife who won't listen
is really a big turn off to a guy I feel
like and on a podcast like it's cool I
mean it gives me content it's cool I'm
not I'm not complaining but like in a
day-to-day relationship like that's
exhausting to men they don't they don't
men don't like to sit around and talk to
us I feel like I'll be the voice for
women that can actually say if you speak
to me where I understand then I can
listen if you're demanding me from
somebody who doesn't have a father
figure in her life like that you have to
understand how to treat certain women
not every woman is going to be the same
and not every man is going to be the
same what outcomes are you looking for
there
um what outcome yeah you don't
understand it no but in terms of
relationships what are you looking for
like do you want to be married do you
want a long time relationship I would
love to I would like to be married I'm
not going to pinpoint and just say like
I'm going to be married tomorrow if it
doesn't happen it doesn't happen but I
feel like my main source or what I'm
looking for is true happiness and peace
irrespectively that's a relationship
because the reason I'm in a relationship
so in a relationship like you were
saying and I agree men tend to be The
Gatekeepers and the decision makers as
to whether something goes to a
relationship or a marriage so if you're
not behaving so what you'll do you're
setting the criteria and saying a guy
has to explain this to a certain way but
as far as relationships and marriage is
concerned you're not in a position to
lay out that criteria it's the guide
that's laying out the criteria and
saying listen
I expect my girlfriend if she trusts me
and she wants to be with me to listen to
what I'm saying it doesn't mean she
doesn't have a voice but ultimately if I
have something to say I can't I haven't
got time to be drawing her a diagram and
giving all these long-winded
explanations if she's not willing to
listen to me she hasn't really selected
me as her man and and another thing like
when you say like what are you looking
for like relationships and marriage it's
not about happiness it's about Duty and
so when a guy when a guy hears and I'm
just telling you this is just from guy's
point of view like when they hear like
what do you want out of a relationship
and they say happiness that's a red flag
because your happiness can come and go
and it's like if you're not happy
tomorrow you're gonna leave and the
number one thing that men look for is
loyalty and so if you're not like to
that that says to a guy like I'll leave
if I'm not happy
and and that with with all the risk that
men have to take today in order to get
married it's it's like you know we're
asking them to do this but we give them
red flags along the way and this is
where there's not a lot of marriage is
going on there's less marriages in
comparison to our parents generation
feminine feminism sorry has given women
an unrealistic expectation of what of
what relationships and marriage really
are you know I I genuinely believe that
and it's not just you know this is like
very common it's not just like I do
these shows four times a week so like a
lot of these answers I think a lot of
answers we have are like kind of
programmed yeah where we don't really we
don't really you know that's what I mean
like we don't really think about it
because like we're sold this Disney
fairy tale from a young age okay so on
that topic this is something that I was
having a conversation with JD another
day I said that love has an expiry date
how do you guys feel oh on that oh I
agree a medium I think love is a Young
Person's game the average person only
falls in love like three times so you
really don't have that many shots at it
um
see the type of love that
wait how many loves are there can you
find it Pearl there's Eros love there's
there's like three separate types of
love I don't know yeah okay I think yeah
because I don't want to quote it wrong
um but I know there's there's different
types of love and I'm gonna toe the type
of love that we want but essentially any
girl that I want like that I want a
future with uh I Wanna Marry I want to
be my girlfriend the type of love she
has to have for me is the type of love
to have for my for my brothers and the
reason I say this is is
we can fly we can go back whatever but
at no point is are we ever going to
break the relationship up between my
brothers and
some guys you you know you won't keep
all friends but for the day ones you're
always gonna fix it even when you're mad
even when this like even if when you
don't speak something is going to bring
the two of you to fix it because you
know that's that deep love when you let
it go too far you know when you get let
it go too far between the and then you
and then you don't speak to someone and
maybe you Buck up to them one time then
you maybe try to you know let's go out
again brand new it's not the same love
that's what happens with relationships
it just takes one person not to give up
as soon as one person says I'm gonna
give up that's it it's all over so I
just I need that type of love that got
all my brothers and my family there's
four types of Love Eros which is erotic
passionate love um filler which is love
of friends and equals uh storage
um love of parents for children and
Agape the love of mankind okay so yeah
so the I was talking about this it was
the second one the love of friends is
that the one I was talking about love
um love of friends and equals it can be
the love between lovers when they've
been together for a long time and are
not so hot and bothered anymore it's
called brotherly love is the city of
Philadelphia the City of Brotherly Love
of course it could be sisterly love but
it is the accepting love of good
friendship that is the love that is your
for good health the love of the touch of
a loved one the fill a lot like lowers
blood pressure yeah you get the idea
that's the love and that's the love all
the mother loves not fake but all their
mother loves our based upon sign that
full of love is the one where's your
Bros and you're gonna yeah you know it's
not it's never gonna break and it's the
and the one and the love only gets
stronger it doesn't fade and that's the
that's the love that that relationship
needed that's the love that I would want
but in this day and age I I was saying
when we had our conversation I feel like
there's an expiry date on love because
it's like you love me until when I can I
can do something and then you'll just
give up on the love and then that's it
the situation is done you're you're now
saying you're gonna move on and start
chatting to other guys just because a
situation happened this is why I don't
know if I could get married because it's
like I could do something maybe do
something that you don't like and then
you're just gonna stop loving me because
of that situation so it's like there's
an expiry date or love you love me until
when are you pressed
why do you say that are you pressed
because me and me and Kyle was speaking
about this I had to let him understand
that
to an extent I understand love has an
expiry date but it wouldn't have had
that expiry date if he but I was gonna
move me back
wait so if he what say that again it's
just a little bit of pettiness put it
this way I felt like the reason why
while I was looking at it like when we
were speaking about it I wouldn't have
had an expiration date for Kyle if I
felt chosen okay sorry this is the alpha
Widow scenario I'm I'm picking up on it
like because the people because he can't
be your friend he can't be your friend
no no because you're not over this like
it's like even what you've just said you
just like I don't even realize we're
about to go back to you and him again no
he was having a healthy no but it is
healthy but there's something awesome if
he's pressed you just ask him he's
impressed no because I was wondering
okay well then yeah I'm I'm everything
you guys say no but no but see what
happened there this is why me as a man I
would not have him yeah as your friend
because already you're thinking back to
Memories now or things like you guys
this is too much this is too close and
I'm not insecure but I know a red flag
when I see it yeah and if I and if I I'm
just gonna be honest with you because
this is a this is education for you yeah
when you meet the guy that you like bro
you're gonna have to don't even wait for
her to do it you do a favor for her and
just step there I will do it yeah
because I've done it the last time but
then obviously like the brother was cool
he's from the ends and it was like there
was no situation in it he knew me from
that we have other friends outside of
that so we've seen it but men lie you
know men lie we like possibly possibly I
don't like that girl forget that girl to
you
if he steps away that still doesn't deal
with the issue of what if the boy if the
boyfriend said to her I don't like I
feel comfortable with this friendship
and she wouldn't listen to what he's
saying you still got an issue and if a
girlfriend won't listen to one thing
there's probably going to be something
later down the line where he says babes
I'm not happy with this and she goes
well
I don't care
and like and this is what I'm trying to
say to you before and because
when you first heard it it sounded like
controlling it sounded like oh you guys
are insecure oh but when you actually
let it play and you speak about it even
you you probably might you know some
things that get brought up you don't
even realize you get annoyed by some
people like oh you're capping you that
would no that's not what you know what I
mean but you should even care what he's
capping about you shouldn't care about
no pettiness you should just be like
but because you've got history and your
families are intertwined literally spoke
about it last week that's why I was like
are you like why are we talking about
this no but it's just a good topic and
based off no it is related to the
conversation hence why I'm mentioning
but I wasn't relating it to us yeah bro
she loved you and you you you for every
reason you was in the right place you
said it already you was young but but
obviously she was hurt by it you're
someone that she grew up with families
were intertwined using a relationship
and then you chose to break up the
relationship and Men typically don't
leave their women I've never ever left a
woman in my life any woman I've been
with has left me I'm not saying I
haven't tried to come back afterwards
but men we don't leave our women like I
said the other day if my if I had a baby
with my misses and she put on weight you
think I'll leave her I'll try to make
her go gym I'll try to and if she didn't
want to lose weight I just got a fat
wife that's it you know what it is I'll
be like you know remember the pictures
when you used to be fly I used to be
skinny but I'm not gonna leave her no
because she's already she pushed out a
kid for me but but she you know what I'm
trying to say to you like so ah man I
just think I think this is cheating
[Laughter]
I'm honest
what am I doing I just asked the
question but then can we throw it back
to say does love have an expiry I want
to hear everybody's opinion no no you
don't think so no my brother do you
think that love has an expiry date
no don't
[Music]
no not if there's a lot of demand then
there's not true love but if it's true
love it never has an expiry date wait I
think I misunderstood your question so
my question is does love have an expiry
so I I meant like it does like over a
certain age I don't think it's love I
think it's respect but I don't think
like if you meet that person like I
think it loves a choice so I'd
misunderstood love is most definitely a
choice I I can agree with you yeah but I
just feel like because I've been in
various relationships it's like as
something can happen and then the woman
will just move different and it's like
you love me until when I'm not saying
I've stepped out or done whatever but
it's like something could happen
something even minuscule and then it's
like the woman will just give up and
then go and be entertained by someone
else so it's like you love me until when
well I think men and women love
differently and I don't think I don't
think women can love men the way men
love women because cause that's why when
I when a man is heartbroken it's a lot
harder for him to go for it then I feel
like when a woman is heartbroken I feel
like men deal with heartbreak a lot
harder than women do yeah but I think
men can love like multiple girls at the
same time I I don't know because I think
if a girl's Alpha widowed too hard like
she thinks about that guy like there are
there are um
I can't remember if it was like a
comment or where I read this but it was
like a lady in her 80s talking about a
dude she dated when she was in her 17.
like and they interview people on the
streets and they said tell me about your
first love and you just Alpha Widow
Alpha Widow Alpha Widow like I don't
know I think like women it's like
it I don't I don't know which one's
worse because they both have it bad but
I don't think like I think men like have
a heartbreak with everyone with girls
it's like we either never want to talk
to you again and like you're dead like
nothing or like it's like the worst
thing that's ever happened we'll talk
about it for years fair enough that's
that's my opinion
what do you think what is his question
you guys
um but the thing is you listed four
types of love right
so I don't know if some types of Love
have an expiry date like obviously
love between friends I don't think
really has an expiry date of the
friendship's still going
um that's a tough one I don't think I
could really answer that hey what day
what it love probably the sex one got
expired
that was probably expire now steamy
passion all of that business yeah I
think that that probably dies down at
some point like you know I mean just
chilling
just chilling at your Walking Chair
she's over there like you're just like
you know what I mean
uh
someone said
Jada's still in love with a two-pocket
dead man uh Alpha Widow that's yeah yeah
that was crazy man for a week yeah cause
like who's Who's down bad worse a will
or Jada like who who got their heart
broken worse no definitely not because
as well when that when that his pride
went downwards okay maybe not down bad
like who like let's say Will and Jay to
break up like Jada leaves who who is the
worst who is the worst heartbreak
Willard now now I would say his will
because he's stuck with her through
everything that's going on including him
going up to Chris Rock and just
humiliating himself in front of the
whole world Jada isn't really losing
anything like she's built up her
credibility if anything I don't feel
like she's gonna lose anything from
separating with him she might even want
to and his will from the outside looking
it looks like his will that's trying to
hold on to it and that's possibly just
because they have kids together but
that's just my perspective on things
that's how I look it from the outside
look at it like and even I just I just
look at that scenario as that protective
scenario situation again let's just look
at this your woman has been disrespected
you might not even you might have been
found that was a violation but she you
looked at her and she's not happy now
you need to go and do something and this
is that thing what I talk about as well
when I keep talking about men and
women's protectors but when we say it
they want to act like we're not but when
will did that so many women were like
defending and saying yeah they
disrespected Jada her hair and she's got
alopecia and this and they forget all
the other stuff that Jade has done they
were just like yeah that's what I want
my man to do but you know what he didn't
even have a problem until he looked at
her because at first he laughed at the
joke himself and then he looked at saw
that she was pissed and then he went
over and said you know I gotta do side
now because if I don't she's gonna come
and chat [ __ ] to me in the bedroom and I
don't want to hear that and as a man we
go through that because you don't want
to hear your woman woman just in your
ear talking rubbish so I feel like he
was pressured into that situation I
don't feel like he doesn't have to off
his own back I feel like he was pressing
into that situation no I fully but I
just use it as another example of just
us men as protectors and what women look
for us to do now if you didn't do that
in that scenario look at like we was
laughing and she looked at him like oh
you're gonna laugh and then he had to
get up and he had to go and become
something and look what he threw and
thrown away and look what he threw away
and this is what I keep talking about
women about about scenarios where men
have to step in and do things and we put
ourselves on our career and all of our
things on the line and people completely
disregarded but yeah can I just say
something it's all on that subject I
think that in itself sends out a bad
message to what's happening like with
women these days because she is another
woman who doesn't listen to her man yeah
yeah you see when there's around a red
table talking remember he said something
about oh I'll give you my permission and
she was like no you don't give me no
permission so this is the message that a
lot of these girls are getting that you
know you can have a man that's going to
go and risk it all to protect you but
you don't have to listen to him when he
says anything you can do what the hell
you want humiliate him and it's all good
you know but it's not the real world
really isn't it and what does it say
about the like what we're teaching men
do except from women
you ever think like even when like um
like when I hear songs from the early
2000s and it's like I don't know it's
like Bob I'm gonna still sing to it but
yeah but it's like like we have all of
these songs about you know that kind of
[ __ ] on men and I feel like we really
haven't taught men to like value
themselves and think highly of
themselves and say like you don't have
to accept that behavior from well then
that's bad behavior and your woman
shouldn't gain weight when she's with
you and she shouldn't sleep around
before she's met you and you deserve a
pure young wife but we we shame them
when we when they want these things oh
this changes these hoes ain't loyal that
was like that was one for the boys yeah
so when those scrubs came out as well
that was probably like well maybe 15 20
years ago maybe longer longer yeah cool
so that song came out a long time ago
this like I'd say relationships were a
lot different where men were a lot more
masculine in those times now
like not to say that men are like [ __ ]
and relationships but we are like taught
to not be as masculine as we once was
like say for example if you look at
these movies that we're watching these
days most guys are
guys that are just tired and they just
get abused by their women in these films
and it's like that's what they want the
role model of a man to be now where the
woman plays the masculine role in
certain relationships whereas before
back in the day the man was like this
much old man that used to go out and do
anything or defend their woman they'll
do anything but now they want their
guide to be little knowledge for example
even the term toxic masculinity is just
it's not real because there's nothing
toxic about being masculine so even
attaching toxicity to masculine it
creates a bad connotation image in
people's mind it's like saying toxic
femininity right
um there's nothing toxic about being
feminine and if you're hyper feminine
that's a good thing so if you're super
masculine why would that be a bad thing
so but when you create a scenario where
where men can't even be what they're
supposed to be naturally see what are
you doing now so you're if a man wants
to be stronger if he wants to go gym if
he wants to be actually you know what I
want to look after my women I'm our
protector all of a sudden now these are
things a lot of things that are
naturally in us and we want to do it but
then when you step out into the world
they're going to tell you no no no no
and make all these things to be bad in
derogatory and misogynistic but in
reality these are just things that are
naturally in our body so when they start
creating uh movies and stuff where they
show hyper feminine males
um it's just the majority of them these
days look at all of the films that are
probably released in the last five to
ten years most of the guys I've just
done out here yeah but a lot of times
women support this so you know it is it
is a lot of women support this idea of
of we don't we want feminine men but
then when they get feminine men in real
life when they meet them you know that's
why they hate them yeah they hate them
because they no one like you said you
want a man to defend you want a man to
do certain things so I just think women
have to really ask themselves what do
they want do you want a man that's gonna
he's gonna sit there with you in the in
you know in Starbucks and you're gonna
talk babe tell me about your friend tell
me what you're gonna take it to the
nails gonna do your hair all of these
things or do you want a man that's gonna
be like actually babes um here here's my
card go buy that send a picture of is
that what you're wearing I'll change
that
um
um I don't want to go there but if you
are going to go there then just make
sure you let me know what you're doing
who you're with like these are just
natural things masculine things that men
are gonna do or do you want a man that
doesn't care where you go who you're
with and it's okay when you're coming
back
um he doesn't you know do you it depends
what you consider love is and if you've
never had that before there's nothing
more than one a man is literally trying
to figure out where you are not because
he's worried oh babe I'm gonna come and
pick you up if you're not driving
actually you know what um I'm gonna go
grab your mum because actually auntie
wants to go to church on a Sunday and I
should go these are all masculine things
that we do but if you've never
experienced it it's because the types of
guys you were dealing with the wrong
types of guys and I've already taken
from some of the things that you've said
is that maybe you figured out some guys
that you should have seen before now we
know this you're 28 you have no children
you have you come from a family with a
father figure in there you have your
sister next to you you know I'm trying
to say to you have your head screwed on
go outside and go and get the man that's
going to take you down the aisle and
it's going to have a beautiful life with
you
and protect you
okay I'm gonna take a second to read
super Johnson
um okay guys like the video we have over
2 000 people watching right now so we're
only at 950 likes we should have a
thousand five yeah we can clap we can
clap
um we should have at least a thousand
five hundred likes unlike history it
takes you two seconds to like it so make
sure you like the video
um okay so bro Dion
is there a spectrum of being alpha or
beta
um C sir DAC Pearl as you show every day
Millennial and gen Z Chad Chasers have
created a zombie apocalypse apocalypse
of alpha widows these two generations of
women are lost to history
um newbie um [ __ ] to be only women
children and dogs are loved
unconditionally a man is only loved
under the condition that he provides
something Chris Rock under a Shepherd so
what she pushed out your so what she
pushed out your kid she's setting a bad
example for y'all's kids by being
overweight the UK Economist I'm confused
how can we build stronger family units
if women are picking bad men black card
lady on the left figures yourself out
and get some kittens Lazarus the five
four king Alpha widowed her there's hope
for me
um
girl in the black skirt is agreeable how
the male guest explained to how the male
guest explains something versus earlier
this shows she wants men to conform to
her type of communication rather than
accepting him being a man and how he
communicates rules for rules for the
rules for thee but not for me Clifford
reigned Pearl where is that I feel tip
jar please get the jar
um NSX yo my wife and I have healthy yo
my wife and I healthy at no prob have yo
my wife and I are healthy with no
problems married at 32 I started IVF the
same year spent 210k on IVF in five
years no child get cracking IVF is a
business they want you in and sell you
hope Doug MPA girl on the left of the
couch needs to get rid of the long
distance relationship and give her some
best guy friend then she might have a
chance the clock is ticking and you're
about to hit the wall at 100 miles per
hour vanity Rose the walleye see when
she goes from Hot Chicken turns into an
anti
um Tails Syl Ranch I'm tired of hearing
about how people feel a dog has feelings
please talk about what you think the
gray matter between your ears was the
only thing that separates you from every
animal see sir doc I don't have a
relationship with my father really no
one would ever guess that thank you moms
independent thought Pro do you consider
Andrew Tate and fresh and fit feminine
because they always speak of about
setting up boundaries Thane Matra 100
Super Chat
um
single single single people should not
date single parents single parents can
date each other and blend families it is
a terrible idea to be a paid wallet in
your house Dustin Denton 500 Super Chat
let's go
um Dustin you are gonna be you're gonna
be the stream you're gonna you're gonna
be the stream sponsor um so if you have
something you want we're going to do a
little better job next time I'm making
this more visible but if you want
something on the wall behind me when I
get back um to the US email me at
justperlythings gmail.com or DM me on
Instagram
just.pearlythings Dustin Denton um
thanks for keeping it real see surdak
the United Nations has declared that 75
bodies is a crime against humanity so
did the World Health Organization yuck
sentience
um Pearl that's a devil's bargain no
real man should accept that deal I would
rather focus on continue continuing to
build my money and reputation all while
being alone for the rest of my life men
don't take the only two choices given
think critically and Forge your own path
Tales from the Syl Branch thank you for
the Super Chat Ladle Mims thank you for
the Super Chat vanity Rose passing the
75 pass on the canned kid hand me the
baby oil 80s Nostalgia guy Pearl looks
beautiful in that dress
um Kerwin Thompson there's a simp in a
checkered shirt on the couch ranjia
Sharma there this is the problem women
don't know the difference between a
confident good man and an arrogant bad
boy bad boys won't protect you neither
will nice guys but a good man will
women's shoes poorly this old lady power
exchange certac it's not that she's
lying because she believes the lie your
honor prosecution wrestle me refresh it
real quick before we close out so let me
refresh guys like the video what are we
at 1.1 1.1 K likes come on 1.5 K we
should get two with this many people in
the chat let's go like the video it
takes two seconds Manny F what people
say that Will Smith did with the slap is
considered standing for standing up for
his woman yeah that's toxically
masculine by modern feminist deemed
unnecessary but yet want it to be done
okay that's it so
um I think we are going to close out the
show so thank you guys for coming you
guys are really fun guest today
um there's a lot of plot twists
um that I did not see coming throughout
this podcast so thank you for you know
keeping it interesting and entertaining
me
um so to close out the show um tell the
people where they can find you if any
social media you want to plug um and any
final thoughts you have
not not a monologue though not sometimes
but yeah any final thoughts on any
social media
okay so you can find me on Instagram or
YouTube who is Kai I do a freestyle show
like a freestyle rap show it's called
freestyles of Kai um I'm gonna be doing
like some programs and stuff that short
TV series and movies coming soon so
please subscribe to my YouTube channel
on my Instagram
um yeah sorry for the plot twist I
wasn't expecting
um Jakira to drop that but yeah boom
we're here put me you know I rap I'm a
rapper yeah jump one yeah yeah
yeah yeah I'm a rapper really yeah yeah
I do I do freestyle all right cool yeah
I'm gonna have to get you on my next
freestyle we're filming in November so
I'll let you know yeah
and you can find me on Instagram at
Touch by Jakes
um my final thought would probably be I
need to pick better men and help you
pick better men too yeah
um Instagram is dini d-e-a-n-e-y
underscore
um and this was a different podcast I
enjoyed myself thank you
yes you can find me on Instagram
Instagram sorry uh gshk underscore
underscore final thoughts yeah
interesting chat
that's about it really I'm present on
Facebook I use jaipuria if I u s h a i p
u r i a and one thing I certainly want
to say is you have to love yourself
first before you find anyone else amen
and you should always practice seeing a
mirror and say I love you that will
really help you find someone whom you
like and not think and demand too much
from them or ask or yourself ask them or
they ask you
that will happen a lot less if you love
yourself first
um yeah my name is China on Instagram
um Tick Tock uh YouTube I think I just
step on account yeah I just um shout out
to everyone that's been dropping me
comments
um I'll be reading the comments yeah
that's why I'm back here so make sure
you follow and yeah thanks to Paul and
all the other guests today like yeah it
was a good show and I hope everyone
learned something from it if you didn't
know anything already I hope you got to
sign out the show so yeah and thanks to
um blessing behind the scenes as well
yeah thank you guys this was a fun panel
to give you guys a round of applause
I'm a big Clapper I like I like having
clapping sessions I just feel like it
makes everything more exciting
um someone said Pearls of Wisdom could
be my album name I'll think about it
um okay guys uh make sure you like the
video on your way out and subscribe to
the channel um ring that notification
Bell also I'm gonna be in the US for the
next two weeks I leave tomorrow so I am
going to Dallas maybe Miami at possibly
if I have time
um LA and Vegas I might do some meetups
while I'm there and um if there's any
podcasts that you think I should go on
make sure you're spamming their chat um
and DM it to me on Instagram we'll see
if maybe I could set it up last minute
we'll see
um subscribe to the channel like the
video subscribe to our two clips
channels Pearl daily and just pearly
clip we just hit 100K and just pearly
Clips so that's exciting we're trying to
get to I think 20K on Pearl daily so
make sure you go subscribe to both
um like the video on your way out and we
will talk to you next time